ايضا مشاهدينا دراسه اظهر دراسه جديده
اظهرت ان الشكل انف الانسان الحديث قد
يكون تاثر جزئيا بالجينات الموروثه من
انسان نياندرتل والذي عاش في ارجاء قارتي
اوروبا واسيا منذ نحو 350
الفريق الدراسه التابعه لكليه لندن
الجامعيه يعتقد ان
تزوجوا مع الانسان الحديث مما يعني ان بعض
الحمض النووي الخاص بهم لا يزال في البشر
المعاصرين اشار ايضا الباحثون الى ان هذا
الحمض
النووي روث يمكن ان يكون قد اثر على شكل
الوجوه البشريه الحديثه وخاصه الانف الذي
يعتقد العلماء انه تطور مع تكيف البشره
القدامى مع المناخات البارده بعد مغادره
افريقيا وفقا للعلماء فان كانت اجسام
النيان
اقصر واكثر اكتنازا عن الانسان الحديث
ايضا كان الجزء الاوسط من الوجه
مما هو عليه الان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات